the job of the imf is to find the
solutions which make everybody better
off sure how it can be done and then
push it argue try to convince the g20
china is both the world's second largest
economy
but it's also one of the poorest
it's a crisis of contagion it's a crisis
of fear and you've got to stop that fear
i want to go straight to our government
to let our government know that
they have to work with their people
the imf was viewed with genuine
repulsion you called in basically these
economic thugs who imposed a dictator
[Music]
most people know the story of a
flight of a butterfly in africa leading
to a tornado
in latin america
and that's very much what this is about
one of the big costs
of interconnectivity
is the exposure to the volatility that
markets bring
we need better multilateral governments
and if we don't get it
our children and our grandchildren
are going to pay the cost of that
[Music]
the imf has to catch up with his time
the institution has been founded uh 60
years ago more than that
and not surprising that finally a lot of
things has to be done to adapt
at bretton woods new hampshire delegates
from 44 allied and associate countries
arrived for the opening of the united
nations monetary and financial
conference to be discussed are plans for
the stabilization of world currencies i
think his hope and aspiration was
for the world to live in a more
cooperative and collaborative framework
for problems to be solved jointly
and to resist the temptation of
countries pursuing national agenda at
the cost of the global agenda they were
really trying to design a durable system
which would have a lot of stability
built into it and to do that they they
felt that they needed to really
constrain the freedom of
of flow of capital and and markets
today things are instantaneous and of
externally big
size
what happens in the u.s market or or in
europe can have devastating effects on
farmers in africa or mining you know
miners or indigenous people in latin
america
these interconnections
do many good things what we did not
realize is
that you know when something is good
there might be a bad side to it and the
crisis has shown that the bad side could
be quite substantial so there wasn't
enough of an understanding of how
cascading failures
in markets that weren't very well
understood could bring the global
economy to its knee
i had in here my office forecast showing
that situation is going to be very bad
the davos 2008 world economic forum
meeting in switzerland has begun
one-on-one to develop some i think which
is fair to say our view is that the
situation is going to be very bad and at
such a level and the global level that
we need a global stimulus what is clear
is that there will be a serious slowdown
and it needs serious response i think
the speech from strascon at davos
did present a new face for the imf
simply because you had somebody at the
very top saying these things people look
at me as if i was just coming for
planet mars or so
and
i remember it took a long time for them
to accept
three months later in april 2008 we had
here in washington the spring meeting
that we usually have every year and i
presented my forecast and they were all
totally upset to the finance minister
saying you know
you're just joking well they didn't say
joking because it wasn't funny but
they say we know you our economy better
than you do it's not going to be that
bad of course not going to be very good
you're not going to be that bad you're
totally wrong and so on
i remember being at the annual meeting
at the beginning of october of 2008 and
seeing people from different countries
come together
and recognize that they were sharing a
very big problem by monday morning the
market had clearly a signal coming out
of washington that global policy makers
get it
that they will do whatever it takes
to stop
this paralysis
and that there was also recognition that
once the crisis is handled we're going
to have to fix the infrastructure
good evening from the g20 summit here in
east london after coming together to try
to forge a global response the g20 in
london was really an unprecedented event
where you had 20 of the world's leaders
coming together and agreeing over a
trillion dollars of additional
stimulus to the world economy there is
something about crises that forced
people to overcome their differences and
come together to solve a collective
problem there was this very nice
coincidence of the g20 existing as a
structure
and the imf being
eager willing and ready to help what has
been done by central banks by
governments on the monetary side for the
first one on the
fiscal side for the ladder
has avoided a possible catastrophe the
london meeting became the vehicle in a
sense
by which the heads of states basically
revitalize the imf as a multilateral
institution
which could provide a collective
response it's very clear that the
emergence of the g20 now is a direct
recognition of the importance and the
weight for global economic recovery of
the growth of these emerging economies
so the brazil's the
china and
india and others that are really
more or less backing
the whole
recovery process now
the g20 summit troubled the imf's
resources and that trebling included a
50 billion
dollar allocation for low-income
countries the first time in history
really as far as i know that facing the
same problem such a
large amount of countries decide at the
same time to put in place the same kind
of policy and for this point of view it
is a
very important point in the history of
multilateralism because it's really the
first multilateral action that's of this
magnitude the g20 has its problems the
imf has its problems but
more and more people in an
interconnected world
understand these institutions provide a
vehicle where we can at least hope for
progress
the imf was viewed with genuine
repulsion it was a the bank of absolute
last resort when the state
and government had failed you called in
basically these economic thugs who
imposed a dictat dialogue was not part
really of the
way that the imf
dealt with africa
then
so most countries including
tanzania in this case felt it's a big
appeal
that they had to swallow when the
economic crisis happened
um the imf itself had to change
radically because the prescription had
failed what i guess we have learned as
imf uh
a lot is that even
sound economic advice that does not
factor in
political and social considerations
is not going to work
the tanzania conference was called as a
part of i think a consultation process
that the imf was having with different
parts of the world africa came to that
event with a very clear set of asks
we
had expected that this would be a
meeting that would
allow the voice
africans to be heard
if you had failed regulation in the
order of magnitude that you've seen in a
country like the united states if that
had been any african country
the imf would have been all over you
like a ton of bricks i've been to a
number of these type of meetings
in my professional
career
that meeting was very candid
we expected imf to change and at that
meeting
we really had a
very good conversation exactly on these
issues
i think imf has come through with
most of what
they promised
they would
do in order to change
introduce greater flexibility
in the way they dealt with
really work in a partnership framework
which i think for most countries
it has been clearly
the case now when i talked to african
finance ministers in that period
their attitude to the imf was completely
different they saw the imf as an
organization that was there to help them
in a time of crisis
rather than to beat them down
and the stigma that i think many asian
countries felt after the asian crisis
when they felt that in their time of
need
the imf made it harder for them i think
that stigma shifted in this crisis where
many countries felt that in their time
of need the imf was there to help let's
be frank after the memories in asia of
the asian crisis the memories of the
latin american crisis in south america
latin american general
the fact it was difficult for the imf to
pretend to be really the global
global institution representing a
universal membership and so on
i do believe that it's
behind us
i don't believe that this wish that i
have of this dream
of a coordinated economy will appear
overnight but i think that we are making
progress in this direction good evening
after 18 months britain today finally
dragged itself out of recession
a handful of earnings reports helped to
revive hopes the economy is improving
as the financial crisis calmed down we
have seen
countries pursue national agendas
that are inconsistent
with other countries national agenda and
as a result
the global economy is now struggling
the recovery is losing momentum
and financial markets are getting
nervous again and it's clear to us that
the solution is not a national solution
it is a global solution so the job of
the imf is to find the solutions which
make everybody better off sure how it
can be done and then push it argue try
to convince the g20 or governments in
general that that's the way to do it we
need an institution to be
where people worry
every day about this issue where this is
their job
that they wake up worrying about it they
go to sleep worrying about it and they
continuously implement it because that
cannot be done at a national level the
purpose of the institution is to help
the leadership of sovereign states
communicate with each other and
sometimes tie their hands a bit and
bring along their citizens for the
greater long run good of everyone i
think that's a worry that you won't see
big changes without you know without a
real change in the policy making and
thinking of a lot of the governments
that own the imf the imf they were part
of the problem
the great struggle now is to ensure that
they are part of some solution if it
must be more proactive it must be
literally the listening bank
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it's pretty reasonable to assume
that at some point someone perhaps in
the middle of the century china will be
15 to 20 of the world and i think that's
a very very positive story
the issue now is how does china keep
this up
it is both the world's second largest
economy
but it's also one of the poorest
[Music]
if we're talking about imf role in the
world
china is a very
successful example
[Music]
china has grown at about nine and a half
percent on average every year for 30
years
and that implies that the chinese
economy doubles in size about every
eight years which is why china has gone
from being one of the poorest countries
in the world when it started its reforms
30 years ago in 1979 to the second
biggest economy in the world today
[Applause]
i joined the people's bank of china in
early 1990s so we were at the early
stages of transition
from a centrally planned economy to a
market-oriented one
so
how to do that that was enormous
challenge
we found out that the fund had a pool of
experience
the imf in china have had a very close
and positive engagement for many many
years we actually have staff posted in
china and we've had that for the last 20
years the advice that the imf has given
china is based on what we see happening
in other countries that have faced
similar situations
china
has done a lot of reform successfully
and i think in this process mf played a
very
constructive positive role
[Music]
probably the main benefit of this rapid
chinese growth is that the poverty rate
in china has fallen dramatically
[Music]
in the early 1980s the rate was about 53
of the population lived in abject
poverty today that rate is eight percent
now
given the size of the chinese population
1.3 billion people
that implies that an estimated 400
million people have been lifted out of
poverty
the striking thing about the chinese
model at the moment is a very state-led
it is that's been particularly true in
its response to the crisis
[Music]
it produced a fiscal stimulus
of a sort that the world has really seen
it also produced a financial and
monetary stimulus that was remarkable
we have supported the response because
we think that the government stimulus
was very helpful it came at the right
time and it helped to cushion the
economy from the worst of the downturn
[Music]
china saw that exports were collapsing
and the chinese government needed to
step in and to support
economic output and they did that
through spending on roads and
infrastructure and on health which
helped them achieve their target growth
rate
[Music]
many of our clients benefited from these
stimulus policies and we benefited from
them as well
therefore yanshan's performance has
shown a stable and persistent growth in
recent years
the biggest challenge for china is how
do you reduce
its uh dependency on
foreign demand for chinese goods as it
is chinese demand is way too low
household consumption in china may well
be the lowest ever recorded for any
country
my impression is that the chinese
authorities recognize very well the need
to rebalance growth away from a heavy
reliance on exports and more towards
domestic demand particularly household
consumption
it will be important to further develop
financial markets
and a stronger currency would help the
exchange rate is
an important part of a package of
reforms that will help to rebalance the
economy
basically we focus on encouraging
consumption and encouraging the
development of a service industry if you
spend a lot of money on social security
on retirement program rural medical
program and so on and so forth you'll
see that the result is the domestic
consumption retail sale and also
domestic demand increase
one of the reasons why chinese consume
so little is because they're very
worried about the lack of pensions that
they have the lack of health insurance
that they have they're worried about the
amount of money they have to spend on
their children's education
[Music]
when we get here we need money to go to
hospital
therefore we save up some money every
month
when i was young i didn't have enough to
save up and the idea of saving didn't
occur to me
i didn't even know what to say foreign
[Music]
i lived through the planned economy
during my childhood and life was hard
then
but there was little pressure as all of
us were in the same situation
that is to say the division between the
rich and the poor was very little
income inequality in china has gone from
being
very flat two or three decades ago to
being really rather extreme and it's
particularly striking given that this is
a country where three or four decades
ago where there was almost no income
inequality
i think china is a developing country
and continue be a developing country for
a long time
we have to have a scientific view of
development and we try to make our
growth more sustainable and balanced
china is very concerned that it can't
achieve an upper middle income country
status it's worried that its growth will
falter it won't be able to lift the rest
of its 100 million people who live in
poverty out of poverty it has all the
concerns that you would expect from a
developing country
[Music]
the efforts that the government has
taken over the last year or two to
broaden and deepen the pension system to
improve the public health system these
are very much steps in the right
direction and we've supported them
there are lots of other very difficult
things that need to be done one of the
most obvious ones is to the whole
situation with migrant workers
[Music]
in 2009 when i came to shenzhen i earned
900 yuan as basic salary now the basic
salary is 1100 but we need to pay 300 or
sometimes 240 for fruit so the raise is
nothing
although many companies are recruiting
many people are looking for jobs as well
the competition is fierce
i don't think the pay is good the
accommodation and food provided are not
good either especially the accommodation
usually they bought several ragged beds
in a tiny room
beds that are provided by some factories
of flea bags
of all
as china is become more and more
urbanized the policy is that dealing
with urban rural divide have to be in
such a way that integration of rural
population affairs
are equal so that those population can
better participate in the city
china could become it's a consumer
market that became one of the driving
forces for the global economy but this
issue of margin workers and the way
they're prevented from really settling
in cities is one of the main obstacles
that's holding that bank
chinese consume way too little
where people are mistaken is in thinking
that consumption is a discrete problem
that can be solved independently of a
major reform of the growth model
that means improving equality on
productivity instead of relying on cheap
labor
on innovation instead of just exporting
lots of goods to the world economy and
all these things require
a much more defined and transparent set
of formal institutions to give investors
and households confidence to invest to
innovate to spend to consume
[Music]
i think the challenge that we are facing
one is china's gdp is getting
larger and larger and the constraint to
us is become more
binding
especially the resources constraint
the energy constraint and also you see
the environmental constraint
the adjustment to other countries as a
result of chinese growth will cause some
to fear china as a threat
there's a growing recognition of the
spillovers of chinese growth for other
countries the value of
the fund in this regard is to provide a
forum for countries to discuss policy
issues
i think that fund has been one of the
key international platforms through
which the international community get
better
understanding of china and also through
which
china gets a better understanding of the
outside world
[Music]
it's a bonanza
it could be short-lived nobody knows
quite how much oil is out there
[Music]
we look at oil as
a second opportunity being given to this
country
there is already quite a bit of
pressure on the government to make a big
splash
i want to go straight to our government
to let our government know that they
have to work with the people
[Music]
well it was back in 2007 that news
reports showed that ghana had made a
world-class oil discovery the true scope
of the size of the field wasn't exactly
known
but it was clear from that moment on
that ghana was soon to join the ranks of
africa's oil producers
once oil comes into production it's
likely that the incomes of ghana will be
raised about 20 percent and the tax
revenues will be anywhere between five
to six percent of gdp and that is quite
substantial
given the
financing needs that ghana has right now
[Music]
2008 was not just the difficulty of the
global crisis we also have very very
serious difficulties enforcement of a
much more serious difficulty in terms of
the internal management of our own
domestic economy
2008 coincidentally was an election year
and in our part of the world
electioneering comes along with what you
call complete
lack of fiscal discipline
by the end of the year there's a record
budgetary deficit
pushing towards 20 and there was a
record trade deficit also pushing
towards 20 percent
so given those difficulties we had no
option but to resort to the fund i mean
for support so in terms of stability the
fund then came in
so the imf has been quite important to
ghana for a long time
that relationship has added
difficulties
and also some smooth
paths
it sometimes also led to the adoption of
programs that were not very popular
but in the end there is no argument
about whether ghana needed a fund or not
the total financing package amounted to
slightly over 1 billion united states
dollars
and in terms of the technical assistance
the fund has been able to increase the
amount of technical assistance that it
has provided to ghana
the imf's view was it came into ghana to
ask the ghanaians what they wanted or to
ask the government what they wanted
it's far less conditional than the the
sort of funding ghana had in the 1980s
the situation was very different what
the government of president mills
inherited in 2009 was a troubled economy
but it was by no means an economy on its
back
given the broad experience that the fund
has had in advising
sub-saharan african and other countries
and the management of the royal wealth
we think we can bring best practice to
ghana's benefit i should say that ghana
has been actually quite eager to learn
from experiences of other countries
dependence on raw materials or depends
on natural resources
per se does not bring about the
transformation of economies in spite of
the huge gold reserves that we've had
we've not been able to attain the levels
of economic transformation that we we so
much longer
[Music]
there's no point in having oil if your
average guardian can't have education
legitimate when you have an oil if
ghanaians can't go to hospitals and get
good health care
there is no point in having oil if
young mothers are going to be dying
in large numbers from
trying to
have children
so the first challenge is how do we
transform the national economy so that
there's value addition
and we can earn more
to run the economy
and that we can
improve the standard of living of
citizens improve their skills
build social capital education water
health
improve the infrastructure
[Music]
so it'd be very important for the
government of ghana to identify
investments where they expect high risk
of return so that even after the expiry
of the oil production right this
investment will continue generating
higher returns going forward
[Music]
if it's done right oil revenues can
really seed the non-oil economy
we need to have a complete reorientation
in terms of our mindset
and understanding that much as we have
natural resources
the greatest resource that we need what
it will focus on is a human resource of
our people
one of the debates in ghana right now is
how can morganians become involved in
the oil sector it's often labeled the
local content
debate
i started this project because i believe
that young people must be empowered so
that this new industry this new oil and
gas industry that is coming to us here
they will be
employable
[Music]
i have a mechanical engineering by
profession but i need before i can get
access into the oil and gas industry i
need to be trained
if you empower people
they become useful citizens
if you leave them they become a problem
to everybody in the society
we have a lot of youth in our area
and we're going to pray to the whole
nation and then the government that we
should employ the youth in our area
we are a developing country
we are a relatively poor country and
people cannot wait to move away from
poverty and underdevelopment so you
cannot fault anybody for being expectant
we are getting the same across all
regions the way to go about it is to
engage much more in educating in letting
them know that we can have an overnight
transformation of the condition of all
our people
it has to be a graduate process
we've invested in
significant outreach in the last few
months to
to explain some of these issues
government efforts in that regard we of
course are listening to the concerns of
the public
oil is a non-durable resource right we
don't know how long
ghana will be an oil producer so it is
important that
the non-oil sector is not ignored
i think one of the priorities for
investments from oil revenue should be
in supporting
small-scale agriculturalists
[Music]
aggregate is the mainstay of the economy
employs most people and most people rely
on that
for their livelihoods
and it contributes the largest portion
to gdp
agriculture in ghana has moved from
fully subsidized agriculture through
partial subsidy
to a point where farmers
had no subsidy at all
we need fertilizer
we need money to till the land first and
then we need the seedlings which we can
nest so that we transplant and
the money is the most important because
without money you can purchase the
fertilizer the chemicals which you have
to spread
so if we don't have access to credit
there's no way we can really adopt the
general technology we are trying to push
so i believe that
access to credit is really a key
if we want to have to develop the
ghanaian agriculture
in other countries where we've worked on
the oil issue we've seen that the
agricultural sector has has dried up and
certainly you want to be able to manage
your economy so that oil which produces
very few jobs is not affecting the
sectors of the economy that are actually
employing people and keeping people out
of poverty
normally when there's an album
the tendency
is maybe to even ignore the soft
commodity successor
like the cocoa sector
but we are putting in place
certain
interventions to make sure that this
doesn't happen they all may come but we
still need to protect our life our
traditional way of life
everywhere you go the ghanaian will tell
you we want we want transparency we
don't want any corruption we don't want
the revenue or revenues to be used
according to the queensland countries of
people who are in government
[Music]
we've certainly worked with the
canadians in terms of improving public
financial management and giving an
opportunity to both parliament and to a
civil society more generally to
understand the budget and to understand
exactly what resources are going where
i think the aim was for ghana to be a
middle-income country by 2020.
it's technically doable but it's going
to require a really determined and
disciplined government to to deliver
that
[Music]
if it is that we can do that we
anticipate that oil will become a
catalyst that can bring about the
transformation we are looking for and
maybe we then can become the kind of
positive example and that could inspire
africa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
countries in central and eastern europe
have been worse hit
by the financial and economic crisis
than probably any other region of the
world
and in that however poland has been an
exception
poland was the only country of the
european union not to plunge into
recession
[Applause]
poland has a chance of becoming an
economic powerhouse of europe
nothing less than that
[Music]
solidarity had a lot to celebrate on its
ninth birthday today it complained to
transform politics in poland and now
it's heading the country's new
government
the promise of 1989 was that the end of
the cold war is the end of the social
antagonism i mean we really
thought after 1989 that there is one way
there is necessity there is one
direction
we and we have no time to discuss it
because we have to catch
up with the western countries
poland had been through a big crisis and
it was faced with how to move into the
modern world how to change the entire
structure of the economy to become
competitive and to become a western
capitalist economy
i think it's got to be said that to a
great many people the change of the
system was a great joy but equally it
surprised them too because suddenly it
turned out that people had full
responsibility for their own lives
for
well-educated people living in a big
cities young enough to
fight on the market it was great time
but the problem was that the big part of
the society was completely excluded and
then frustrated
unemployment is expected to pass 1
million this year
warsaw's job office has never been so
busy almost no one was listed as
unemployed a year ago
now poland has four hundred thousand
people looking for jobs
those people
found it extremely difficult to become
re-employed many of them really became
marginalized so they were
those who lost
was it going to work well
i do remember documents inside the fund
which gave it a 50 chance of working but
the polish policy makers were determined
to do it they had the courage to do it
and we didn't have the option then not
to support such a courageous bunch of
reformers
what we are doing
is
to assist your government
in the design of its program and it is
our job in the imf to put up its
disposal
our experience
and our
knowledge of this kind of problems
not only was there a communist economy
but also didn't have
a lot of skills necessary to simply run
the market economy so some technical
assistance was absolutely
crucial
[Music]
for me it was very great time because if
somebody had a good idea and a little
bit money that was a very big
possibility to make anything it was not
only for money it was very big uh spirit
feelings that our products are finding
place
in our customers
within poland there's always been you
know people are very individualistic
and they don't like to be told to be
told to be ordered around and obviously
a good way of not being ordered around
is to be your own boss
so 20 years ago we have started this
firm with my partner in a small garage
with two persons
in this time we had used only
cash so
the cash flow was very speedy we have
possibility to buy new things new
machines it was very easy
getting rich that was the main idea
behind
almost everything that happened in
poland in terms of economics of course
getting rich and getting normal
so the initial success was due to the
entrepreneurship of polls but then the
big step forwards was due to the fact
that poland started to attract a lot of
the investment
relaxes bogaccio
the market was developing there was a
growing abundance of goods we'd lived in
this homespun poverty for so many years
and everybody was really enjoying all
that
and now all these things are made in
poland only brands are foreign but the
product is ours
our growth was not very impressive first
years we had even negative growth but
after some period of time the economy
started growing faster and faster and
faster and in mid-90s the growth
achieved even seven percent growth
and among the countries represented at
that eu enlargement reception was poland
it's the largest of the 10 countries
joining on saturday but what does eu
membership mean for its people
polls wanted to work and live in a
normal wealthy country
and they did everything possible to
achieve this and they did achieve this
everybody wanted to join um european
union it was for us a destiny for a long
time we really wanted to be in this club
[Music]
the transformation has been so fast and
so
extensive by this point that
most people have become reconciled to
this process but there were losers
certainly
it's inevitable when you move from
socialism to a market economy that
you're going to have an increase in
inequality but what we know and poland
is a very good example is that those
countries which moved fast
to reform
have seen the smallest increase
in inequality
[Music]
the collapse of lehman brothers set off
a wave of panic on wall street
we thought that the whole world has gone
crazy
we were looking at the stock markets in
new york in london in warsaw
and we saw things we could not
understand
we became anxious and and we started to
observe and the first action of the
government i should say
was that we have to
cut our expenditures of course the
financial crisis was also not
nice for us because we are exporters
especially for the east countries like
russia ukrainia and so on
obviously some problems did appear
a bigger budget deficit a bigger public
debt but for the time being it seemed
the real economy in poland did not
suffer and the financial sector the
banking sector did not suffer
probably poland is the only one country
around the globe that has
that limit to gdp written to
constitution
so this was one of the key elements that
the law debt which in relation with very
responsible fiscal policy resulted in
solid fiscal position
we were much more prudent we really did
not lose our minds in the good years
before the crisis
poland had followed more stable policies
than its neighbors but we were concerned
that the there could be a lot of
spillover from these neighboring
countries when you're dealing with the
crisis of this kind it's a crisis of
contagion it's a crisis of fear
and fear picks
the weakest off but then moves on to the
stronger ones and you've got to stop
that fear and the way to stop that fear
is by international solidarity
[Music]
poland's situation was actually quite a
bit stronger than the other countries
and that's why the imf was very happy to
give poland support under the flexible
credit line
and poland was an ideal candidate for
this it was a country with strong
policies and yet there was the risk that
there could be a spillover from
the crisis in neighboring countries
so this is very scary that sometimes
people make decisions without having
knowledge about the situation in
particular country
it was a perfect time
for the fund to come with a new
instrument
poland was assessed as a strong and
economy with solid fundamentals which
also was very helpful and it it also
supported polish government
in front of investors and in front of
the markets
nothing has changed as far as the facts
are concerned but the perception of
those facts has changed and here the fcl
was a clear signal that the fund
believed in poland and in a way that it
also believed in the whole of the region
[Music]
the crisis offered us a very unique
opportunity
we always thought that it would take us
30 years maybe 40 years to catch up with
the brightest in the european union now
because of their recession and our
positive stable growth the period it
will take us to catch up with them will
shorten
one thing we have really learned from
the polish experience is that if the
policymakers have the courage
to
take action in a most difficult
situation they can achieve remarkable
things
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you